do it I welcome death as far back as
April of 2018 I always wanted to be a
Buffalo Bills Bills laughs yeah hey I'm
just happy to be here the bills mafia
did what they wanted
viral it was Singletary what can I say I
can't be tied down betrayed the Killa
it's a good book boys head little Stevie
kicks [ __ ] the kickin me Jay cold
Beasley my name is Cole Beasley and I'm
here to say I like to rap in a very
white way I coach Shawnee McDermott er
hey you've always having fun don't okay
culture chain and then there was the
gore father will make him an offer he
can't refuse
come play ice football be a warm is for
children we whacked our opponents the
old-fashioned way with defensive
football that was super boring leave the
ball take the wings sauce so hot
actually let's leave him alone enjoy
your meal sir and now we're on the run
nothing I think I'm a running
quarterback
[Music]
hey you yeah all freakin hundred
thousands of you flippin listen to me
I'll be out about the anything lurkers
watching RBS so subscribe this cheesy
channel or GT the fluff Oh daddy says
subscribe